today you are going to see a lot of
papers come alive in the world around us
why well Nvidia just announced their
shiny new h200 graphics card and this is
a big deal in fact to say it is a big
deal in my opinion would be an
understatement but first bad news it is
pricey few if any of us are going to be
able to buy this so I hear the question
caroy why do we have to speak about a
graphics card that we won't buy well I
have good news too we don't have to buy
it and yet each of us can still enjoy
their advantages I'll tell you how in a
moment and first let's roll up the
sleeves and have a look at what they can
do so what are the advantages of such
Hardware well it can simulate a landing
on Mars power superc computers or r a
fusion reactor simulation and it can
perform these beautiful fluid
simulations tornado simulations and
visualize solar flares or do protein
folding this leads to a better
understanding of the building blocks of
life and it is already being used for
creating new kinds of medicine something
that was so difficult we always thought
was only going to happen in the future
and now now it is here of course these
graphics cards also power video games
and what is this here dear fellow
Scholars this is 2minute papers with Dr
Caro okay kidding this is an
aerodynamics and acoustic simulation
around this new car new hardware can
typically do more intensive tasks than
previous generations or it can do the
same tasks and consume less energy like
it is doing here something that we have
to think about more and more in the
future you see the jump from gpt2 to GPT
4 requires orders of magnitude better
Hardware consider this gpt2 had 1 and A2
billion parameters gpt3
175 billion paramet a jump of more than
100x then GPT 4 more than 1 and a half
trillion parameters
a,x difference this requires tons and
tons of compute and today specialized
versions of it already exist get this
where scientists created a chemistry
assistant that can not only answer your
burning questions about Metal organic
Frameworks but it also learned to
predict crystallization outcomes as well
and today Nvidia can train a gpt3 AI not
in years and not even in days but hold
on to your papers fellow scholar and
look less than four minutes what oh my
goodness also stable diffusion in less
than two and a half minutes incredible
AI systems are now being trained in a
matter of minutes my mind just refuses
to comprehend this and it just got e
even better this is with the old h100
graphics cards and they now announced
h200 this has almost double the memory
capacity wow this is one of the main
limiting factors in how big of an AI
system we can get access to and it just
got nearly doubled memory bandwidth is
now up 40% and almost broke a mouth
watering 5 tabes per second we are
almost there and of course things are
going to run faster too way faster
loving it so good and B 100 is coming
next year so make sure to subscribe and
hit the Bell icon if you would like to
hear me flip out over it of course if it
is any good from the extrapolations wow
buckle up fellow scholar it is going to
be real good so this Hardware improves
all things Ai and today AI is a piece of
software that writes new kinds of
software see where this is going this is
the engine of scientific development and
we just got a new engine and compute
power just keeps increasing at an
incredibly rapid pace and today no field
of research no branch of science remains
Untouched by these techniques so why is
this good news for all of us well even
if we we don't buy this Hardware this
Powers the tools we use day by day chat
GPT and many other AI tools that are
absolutely everywhere I am also happy to
see Lambda our long-standing partner
showcased here great job and remember
92% of Fortune 500 companies use CAD GPT
and we haven't even talked about any
other AI here and two it is also fueling
the next iteration of research works it
is fueling the papers so we fellow
Scholars are very happy to see this and
one more thing about increasing Hardware
capabilities that put this image into
perspective in AI research there is or
perhaps at this point I can say there
only was two schools of thought one
Richard Sutton argues in his Landmark
article by the name the bitter lesson
that AI research should not try to mimic
the way the human brain works he argues
that instead all we need to do is
formulate our problems in a general
manner so that our learning algorithms
may find something that is potentially
much better suited for a problem than
what our brain is doing and he argues
that the best performing learning
techniques are the ones that can
leverage computation or in other words
methods that improve significantly as we
add more compute power to the utter
school of thought people tried to encode
lots of human knowledge of strategies in
their go AI but did not have enough
compute power to make a truly great
algorithm and now we have Alpha go which
surprisingly contains minimal
information about go itself and yet it
is better than the best human player ERS
in the world so what does all that mean
well in other words algorithms are
extremely important I don't need to
argue for that on this channel but never
forget compute is just as important and
this graphics card is a metric ton of
more compute turns out for all of us
even if we don't buy it ourselves what a
time to be alive if you're looking for
inexpensive Cloud gpus for AI Lambda now
offers the best prices in the world for
GPU Cloud compute no commitments or
negotiation required just sign up and
launch an instance and hold on to your
papers because with the Lambda GPU Cloud
you can now get on demand h100 instances
for just1 199 per hour yes
$199 and they are one of the first Cloud
providers to offer publicly available on
demand h100 accs did I mention they also
offer persistent storage so join
researchers at organizations like apple
MIT and ctech in using Lambda Cloud
instances workstations or servers make
sure to go to lamb.com
slapers to sign up for one of their
amazing GPU instances today